this week on quadriga german august does
miracle have a plan b refugees continue
to arrive in germany at the rate of
three to four thousand a day in a recent
poll 60 percent of Germans said
Chancellor Merkel has lost control of
the situation the sexual assaults in
Cologne have prompted calls for tougher
border controls and making it easier to
deport refugees how old Chancellor
Merkel cope with these new pressures
does she have an alternative plan coming
to you from Berlin quad Riga the
international debate your host this week
Melinda Crain hello and a very warm
welcome to quad Riga Angela Merkel is
still saying we can do it is she
bluffing that's one of the questions we
want to talk about here today with three
guests who've been following the refugee
crisis very closely it's a pleasure to
welcome Judy Dempsey she works as a
senior associate at Carnegie Europe and
editor-in-chief of strategic Europe and
she says for the first time since
becoming Chancellor in 2005 Merkel has a
plan it's to rescue Europe from falling
apart the problem is that it's a plan
without support from other EU member
states and Alan Posner is with us once
again he's an anglo-german author and
regular commentator for the Berlin based
newspaper de Velde he thinks Merkel
never had a plan not for the euro crisis
not for the refugee crisis not for
dealing with populism in Germany and
across Europe and finally glad to see
Eric Kirschbaum once again with us he's
working for reuters and is currently a
correspondent for the los angeles times
in berlin he says usually Angela Merkel
has things figured out with the end
result in mind this time she doesn't
seem to have an end in mind and that
could cost her and her conservative
party dearly this year
so two out of three of you say the
Chancellor has no plan neither a plan a
nor a plan B but Alan Posner she repeats
like a mantra the need for one quicker
processing of asylum applications at
home and B the need for greater
cooperation at home both within Europe
and between the European Union and
Turkey
so those sound like elements of a plan
oh yes I mean there are things you have
to do if people apply for asylum they
need to get their application done
quickly and if they are refused they
need to be sent back quickly now I'm
just talking about a million coming
about half of whom might be applicable
you're gonna send 400,000 back how are
you gonna do it that's one thing second
thing and more importantly is it neither
within our own coalition nor within the
wider German spectrum nor within Europe
is anyone there who's gonna throw her a
lifeline no one's taking refugees in no
other European country in any numbers
which are gonna help her before turkey
does anything more it's gonna be a long
time so you know her plan if this is her
plan let Europe help me then that plan
has failed already by the way I think
she knows that we're gonna come right
back to some of those obstacles there
Eric here's problem if I look at the
Chancellor's recent statements her
statement yesterday to her rather
recalcitrant Bavarian sister party her
statement in her New Year's address and
to her own party meeting in December I
have to say she's sounding more resolute
perhaps than at any time in her term in
office
she says putting up border fences trying
to stop refugees at the border is not a
workable alternative she does have a
point doesn't she well she's she's got
the European Union in mind she's got the
future of the European Union in mind and
and that is a big problem that the
people who want her to introduce caps
don't really seem to have a plan for
either what's gonna happen if they do we
put the border controls back up it's
really gonna set the whole EU back a big
big step I think miracle has gotten a
trouble because this winter everybody
thought the number of effort geez would
start to go down in the winter nobody
would come across anymore
but they're still coming in by 3,000 a
day so they're gonna have another
million at this rate at that at this
rate this year anyway so that's why
there's all this pressure now and the
winter on miracle she's hoping for a few
more few more months of times the next
EU summit but people in her party aren't
happy about her and she is definitely in
trouble I think speaking to members of
that Bavarian sister party yesterday
Judy Dempsey Merkel said once again that
she's looking to the future as Eric said
trying to buy a bit more time said she's
counting on two things one consultations
this week with Turkey between Turkey and
the EU and number two yet another
meeting of EU leaders in February is
there any reason to expect that meeting
to produce more cooperation than we've
seen in the past months no and nor is
there any hope that President Erdogan of
Turkey is going to cooperate I mean he's
been stung badly by the whole Islamic
state and the recent suicide attacks two
weeks ago in Turkey so I think is going
to be very loath to keep the refugees
there although this is part of the EU
package secondly how many summits have
the EU had over the refugees as if they
didn't see this problem happening two or
three years ago and there is a plan be
on the table at this summit and there's
going to be a plan B that many of the 28
member states will not accept
essentially being in your core of
countries who will keep the borders open
and an outer core if you don't cooperate
for the refugees well then the borders
will be closed it may be radical that's
one of the options but Merkel is not
going to be handed any kind of support
it she's in a very difficult situation I
want you to elaborate on that Plan B
that you mentioned in just a moment but
first let's take a look at some of those
numerous EU summits and the resolutions
that they've issued which in fact have
not been followed up upon example Turkey
the EU as promised turkey three billion
euros if it will reduce the number of
refugees it allows to come to Europe
but Italy is reported to be blocking the
deal as a result turkey is stalling on
its end of the agreement a small part of
the Mediterranean Sea is now governed
not by the rule of law but by people
smugglers example hotspots by the end of
2015 Greece was supposed to have set up
five refugee reception centers known as
hotspots but the EU says that so far
there's only one Italy said it would
organize six centers but so far there
are only two example redistribution
160,000 refugees are due to be moved
from Greece and Italy to other EU
countries so far the EU says only a few
hundred have been relocated why has
European solidarity failed to function
in this situation are some EU states
trying to punish Germany because it's a
key player in Europe Alain Posner last
summer the Hungarian Premier referred to
the refugee crisis as quote Germany's
problem what if anything could change
that view of the matter what could
finally impel European Member States to
actually make good on all these
different things that they've resolved
to do basically nothing
I mean Albin you I can't even begin to
say how horrible that statement is
because it was Macker who helped him out
of a crisis we saw these thousands of
refugees in the Budapest main station
Makris had come to Germany so she helped
him out of a tight spot mr. Albin is
just unthankful but so is everyone
grateful but so is everyone else in
Europe and most have much more reason
for that then Hungary does I mean the
fact that the Greeks don't want to help
us see when did we help them in the
crisis the fact that Eastern European
states are one of us they are angry at
us because we've been cooperating too
much with Russia over their heads
everyone has a grudge against Germany
and most of them for good reason not mr.
Orban by the way but most of the others
so they're not going to help Germany
it's not gonna happen but but from
orbitons point of view Merkel did make
it worse by making it look like the
gates were open the doors are open
the Germany will take care of you and
that just added to the number of people
going and rushing to get to Europe
before the gates closed
I think Merkel's miscalculation is
twofold one is that she hasn't got a
strategy to do with the refugees but
actually she also wanted to believe that
welcoming the refugees opening the
borders would actually trigger a plan
new response and it didn't she was
hoping she was calculating yes if I do
this other countries will follow and
they didn't follow for many complicated
reasons so Judy you said you could
imagine that at the February meeting of
the EU that some carrots or at least
some sticks might be laid on the table
can you say another word about that and
whether you think that actually will
change the calculus of other India
member states there are two elements
that being discussed at the moment one
is that relieve the pressure on Italy in
Greece Greece clearly cannot deal with
the problem and move more of the
refugees try to start relocation the
refugees to the more prosperous northern
countries and you know who that includes
Sweden but sweeteners closing its doors
Denmark it's disgraceful what they're
doing Britain do you think Cameron will
do this before the election at the
referendum on the EU this is one of the
proposals I don't see this flying and
the other is and we have to really watch
this how the German Finance Ministry
will see the future of Europe the B one
European the one passionate European
left among all the EU governments is
Wolfgang surely the finance minister he
knows that if to Sheng an open border
system collapses that is the end of the
euro that is the end of the internal
market and the economies will get even
weaker so you could imagine sharable of
being what he is thinking well let's
have it maybe a two-speed Europe but you
always wanted those who want to
cooperate with the refugees we keep the
borders open those who don't want to
like the central East and East Europeans
in other countries okay we're close can
we close the borders it's highly
provocative and that's where the curtain
sticks could come in eric kieron there
has been talk in the past of possibly
saying to those countries that don't
want to cooperate Eastern European
countries perhaps even some southern
European countries okay you don't have
to take refugees in and to actually give
them asylum but you have to pay and
maybe pay a lot wouldn't that change
people's behavior in Eastern Europe it
could but you have to get a majority to
agree to that and it's probably not
gonna happen either the foot draggers in
Europe are following the discussion in
Germany very closely they see that
Marco's losing support in Germany she's
been super popular for the last 10 years
and all of a sudden support is crumbling
they're following that very closely they
see the debate between the CSU and the
CDU they know miracle is losing her
position and why should they
why should they help her out now let her
sink own poster yesterday the Austrian
leadership said we want to limit the
number of refugees our country will take
in and in all fairness to Austria
they're talking about a limit of 1.5
percent of their entire population that
is not a small number let's look at
other countries in the world US UK they
haven't taken anything like that number
believing that aside briefly the
Austrian leaders also said this is a
wake-up call to the rest of Europe will
that call be heard we have that to
change behavior yeah well I mean this is
what's gonna happen I mean I like Judy's
idea or mr. Schwab euler's idea possibly
but that's not what's gonna happen
what's gonna happen is if I stray close
its borders that relieves Germany of
course basically they've closed our
board of Horace thank you very much
Austria Macedonia the same day or the
evening of the same day closed their
borders to Greece so people aren't
coming up through Greece and Serbia
towards Slovenia and and Austria so this
is what's this is the plan be by default
everyone closes their borders except
Germany
mrs. American pretend that she hasn't
closed the borders but basically she has
and then what happens when people are
dying in the winter in the Balkans and
then what's going to happen that's also
a wake-up call what would that the
wake-up call is out there and it's
ending the war in Syria and in Iraq
totally totally this is not it's not
here in Germany it's not here in Sweden
Austria it's out there and prayer is the
diplomacy and the power to actually the
political will to stop it
so Eric Pierce bomb Europe tends to move
very very slowly it often acts only if
the wolf is at the door so let's say the
wolf is at the door in the form of
images of refugees freezing in tent
cities in the Balkans let's say the
Chancellor is right and
does possibly lead to some movement
within Europe so simply a need for more
time how much time does she have
how much time does she have when we look
at the internal political situation here
in Germany I don't think she has a lot
of time left in Germany I think the it's
closing in quickly on her the CSU has
been banging the drum more and more
people are fed up with the situation
especially since the events in Cologne
on New Year's Eve that's really putting
the pressure on her but a year ago 800
people drowned off the coast of lumpa du
Xia the EU oh this is horrible and then
they went back to business as usual
nothing really changed I mean I hope we
don't have to see hundreds of people
thousands of people freezing to death in
Greece but I can imagine it'll be a
short reaction of the Theo and then
it'll be fruit it'll go on to the next
problem
I don't think Merkel has a lot of time I
think the next few weeks are really
going to be decisive for her how long
she'll be Chancellor and this is
something a few months ago we were
talking about this Oh she'll be around
forever but I think she she might not
make it to the end of the year so our
title refers to German angst which may
of course come as a surprise to some
viewers who remember those amazing
pictures of warm welcomes last summer
the Vil komen school tour but the mood
has shifted let's take a look September
2015
Germany welcomes refugees with open arms
four months later following the sexual
assaults in Cologne the mood has changed
you listen you know in the past we sold
between 150 and 200 pepper sprays over
the course of one year now frankly every
day we sell a hundred pepper spray one
tall Newton in several cities people
have joined civilian defense groups
refugees have suddenly become suspect in
one city mail asylum-seekers were banned
from a public pool after several women
said that they'd been harassed if they
don't behave they're out period
local officials in one town called off
this year's Carnival parade citing fears
of possible Cologne style attacks and a
mayor in Bavaria sent a busload of
Syrian migrants to Chancellor Merkel's
office in Berlin because he's upset
about her policy on refugees
his Germany on the verge of a nervous
breakdown
Alan Posner what accounts for the shift
in mood and how widespread is that we
had some very egregious examples there
but of course that is anecdotal what's
the evidence how great is the anxiety
well you know I think New Year's Eve in
Cologne that was a tipping point when
over a thousand women in North
rhine-westphalia not only in Cologne and
other cities across the area were
sexually harassed molested in one or two
cases possibly raped by people of they
say North African Arab descent
the facts are still murky but the fact
is that a sort of an underlying axis
been there for years actually the angst
about these testosterone-fueled young
men suddenly burst out and people well I
think we could include this whole round
who are in the liberal centre mainstream
find themselves caught between two fires
because you don't want to be
anti-immigrant you certainly don't want
defend attacks on women and this I think
has has has the mood means that the mood
is turning uglier by the day Judy
Dempsey statistics show that every
second German woman claims to have
encountered sexual harassment in the
past is it truly likely to become more
prevalent or more egregious because of
this influx of refugees sexual
harassment is a fact of life in all
cultures I think the whole issue will
become more exaggerated and more
complicated actually and and I think
basically the summer comes when women
will want to be feel comfortable wearing
shorts or skirts or whatever and there's
going to be quite there's going to be
very different pressures on them I'm
actually quite worried about this but on
one other thing when you mentioned did
cologne change anything actually I think
there's a parallel connection the civil
society movements and the volunteer
movements they are asking when is this
going to end we have we're dealing with
100 people next week 320 next big they
want they want some guidance friend will
it stop and Chancellor Merkel can't give
him that if you can get them no
assurances there at kiss from the
President of Germany spoke in Davos this
week and said look we do need to get the
numbers of refugees down because
otherwise we have a major problem with
the public ability and willingness to
absorb the refugees is that correct and
does that mean that the public at this
point is really at its absolute limit
it's getting close to the limit I mean
where exactly the limit is I don't know
but I think cologne did change the mood
and I think gallic does have a bit of a
he's a bit freer to express the view of
the public and I think he realizes that
they need to come up with a plan they
need to give the people a sense that
were in control of the situation again
Germans love being in control and the
sense that their country is running out
of control being overrun by millions of
refugees each year with no real plan
I've something it's really difficult for
Germans that it digest and cologne for
example for an American it's unusual to
see women walking alone having a good
time midnight and as in a German city
you don't see that in a lot of cities in
America you don't see that a lot of
seasons around the world but Germany has
this tremendously liberal civilized
society where everything is so free and
so but you know the fact is that a
policing problem in Cologne they had far
too few officers they drastically
underestimated what would be going on
there on New Year's Eve they're talking
about it they've replaced their police
chief they're hiring new officers and
we're seeing all through Germany one of
the most intensive and I must say
constructive debates on integration that
I've heard in my many years in this
country so are we really so sure that
they're not capable of getting this
under control they can't get it under
control but Germans swing under in
different directions they go swinging in
the one direction in the other direction
and cologne as you mentioned is the
tipping point it here with a tale of two
train stations we have the Munich train
station September and the Cologne
stretch changes in New Year's Eve
Germans have gone to the extreme the one
end so welcoming and then to the extreme
at the other end
they need a third train station to come
up with a little ground I don't know
what about the political leaders we
certainly are seeing that pressure
within the Chancellor's party so far
she's remaining steadfast what about her
junior coalition partner the SPD how
much support
are they still willing to give her well
you know politically the SPD is left
already they're already demanding a
limit to two refugees I mean the SPD is
overtaking her on the ride her CSU
partner is there already so she's
totally isolated but they're not gonna
get a do away with her for one very
simple reason no one wants to take the
rap they want her to get to take all the
flag to solve the difficulties before
you know you don't want to be chance of
Germany at this moment none of us would
like that job because it's impossible
job that's why they're gonna leave it
with Marco so mess so sorry but back to
the title of our program German anxiety
plan B Judy Dempsey clearly she's
counting on getting those numbers of the
refugees down some form of European
cooperation coming in future let's say
all of that doesn't happen what might
another Plan B look like the Austrians
are calling their decision to impose a
cap a plan B would that be an
alternative for Germany no the
alternative is actually ending the war
in Syria I go back to this point closing
borders Merkel is right when this
closing borders will not solve the
problem or solve the problem is getting
the Iranian and the Saudis and the
neighbors in the region ending this
bloody war in Syria again something that
will take a considerable amount of time
here at Kerr spam you told us she
doesn't have a lot of time this Austrian
move reimposing border controls the
Austrians are saying we're only going to
let refugees in at one crossing point
everywhere else we're going to shut it
down is that the beginning of the end of
free movement within Europe the
so-called Schengen Agreement and if so
is that Plan B the breakdown of Schengen
it could be it could also just be a way
to pressure the EU to come up with
something because if the borders to go
up everywhere on Schengen does fall the
e used I'm a problem as well the
economic growth will will shrivel away I
mean I think really pivotal is these
March elections in these three Eastern
and three German states
you candidates get routed there do
poorly the pressure on Mirko could be so
enormous that something will break in
mid in more in mid-march who has a plan
B Alain Posner you've told us the
Chancellor doesn't does one of the other
political parties and do you see a
workable plan B well no the chanson de
chanst has always said in all the crisis
you know we're driving like in a fog
that's the way she's going she's been
incredibly lucky now that the Austrians
have shut the board and the Macedonians
that is their right the Austrians that's
Plan B shut the border but I agree
totally with Judy we're not gonna solve
anything until we fix Syria we've gained
some time we're gonna gain some time by
closing the borders Merkel is still
there now we need the political world
and the terrible tragedies we're in an
American election year where an American
president is gonna lead on that that's
why that's not gonna happen
that's a tragedy and double tragedy is
that America's not taking in the
refugees to lift the pressure off
Germany that's him
yeah so solving the Syrian war clearly
that is not a plan B that's a plan a
they are working on it
German Foreign Minister Steinmeier as
well very much involved what kind of
prospects do you give the current talks
we're due to see another round early
February I think Iran is a key player in
this of course in Saudi Arabia's
actually been punished with it with the
collapse of the energy prices and he's
got his own economic problems now and
it's it's up to its neck in what it's
doing in the war in Yemen but there must
be a meeting of minds among the region
and among the Europeans that this war
has to end waiting for Obama's that the
end of the Obama era waiting for a new
president come in we don't have time in
our hands one other point there may be a
lot of schadenfreude among the Central
and East European country about Merkel
but tell me do they really want a
weakened Germany and to see the end of
Chancellor Merkel Kerschbaum you told us
you think she doesn't have a lot of time
if there were some kind of progress
evident on Syria do you think that that
would buy the Chancellor more support
within the population at large after all
as you said her poll numbers were
sky-high just a few months ago yeah it
could I mean if
she's right that the piece or an earring
piece in Syria could change the whole
calculus of everything but those are a
lot of big ifs and it doesn't look like
it's on the imminent horizon and people
in Germany are a bit impatient so I
don't think she has that much time
meanwhile as we said much hinges on
whether the numbers actually come down
Alan Posner the government spokesman
said yesterday they are falling is that
just because of winter weather or are
Germany's attempts to get the
registration process and the process of
quickly identifying those refugees who
don't have a right to asylum finally
beginning to work well it's a
combination of all sorts of things I
mean we're deporting twice as many
people as we did a year ago which is a
good thing and not letting them hang
around there's the weather there's the
closing of the borders Bulgaria's
closest border to Greece and Macedonia
is closest border to Greece all sorts of
things are happening the numbers are
coming down and they will come down the
Prophet don't want lose sight of the
events suffering and humanitarian
tragedy that has beset the majority of
these refugees thank you very much
thanks to all of you for being with us
today
and thanks to you out there for tuning
in see you soon